forschung wird in deutschland
hauptsächlich mit öffentlichen geldern
finanziert
deswegen finde ich haben wir ein recht
darauf zu wissen woran damit geforscht
wird wissenschaftler veröffentlichen aus
diesem grund ihre ergebnisse in
sogenannten fachmagazinen die
wichtigsten magazine gehören aber
privatwirtschaftlichen verlagen und die
entscheiden welche ergebnisse sie
veröffentlichen und damit auch welche
forscherinnen und forscher karriere
machen und sie werden dabei richtig
reich die wichtigsten
wissenschaftsverlage machen mit
steuergeldern so viel profit dass apple
amazon und google neidisch werden
könnten warum das so ist und welche
fatale irrtum dahinter steckt das
erkläre ich euch jetzt in unserem
zweiten blick auf die dunkle seite der
wissenschaft
wir müssen publizieren das ist unsere
währung
das natürlich der steuerzahler
forschungsergebnisse sollen zugänglich
sein für die öffentlichkeit aber
natürlich auch vor allem für andere
forscherinnen und forscher deshalb
veröffentlichen wissenschaftler schon
seit dem 17 jahrhundert ihre
forschungsergebnisse als artikel in
fachmagazinen
zunächst wurden diese nur von
wissenschaftlichen gesellschaften
herausgegeben für sie war die
verbreitung von wissen wichtiger als
profit und diese gesellschaften gibt es
auch heute noch aber der markt wird
inzwischen von privatwirtschaftlichen
verlagen beherrscht über 300 jahre lang
war das gedruckte journal oder auch das
gedruckte buch die einzige möglichkeit
wissen zu verbreiten
eine alternative dazu steht uns erst
seit dem internet zur verfügung aber als
das so richtig in mode kam hatte sich
die wissenschaft schon längst von den
großen wissenschaftsverlage abhängig
gemacht die verlage verkaufen also die
fachartikel und die sind gar nicht so
billig ja vielleicht auch schon mal vor
so einer paywall gestanden da werden
zwischen 30 und 40 euro für ein einziges
pdf verlangt und das obwohl man gar
nicht wirklich weiß ob der inhalt auch
wirklich interessant ist forschende an
der uni zahlen zum glück nicht für jeden
einzelnen artikel die uni bibliotheken
taufen stattdessen abonnements auf die
alle studierenden und alle forschen in
einer uni dann zugreifen können aber
auch die sind super teuer nur warum naja
die verlage müssen ja auf jeden fall das
magazin drucken sie müssen es im
internet verfügbar machen und es
vermarkten und verkaufen
aber das kostet bei der heutigen technik
und logistik eigentlich kein vermögen
mehr mp3 ist kann man ja auch für unter
2 euro pro lied kaufen und ein spotify
abo kostet auch keine 10.000 euro im
jahr aber gut hinter so einer pdf
stecken natürlich auch monate und jahre
forschungsarbeit teilweise von riesigen
teams aus absoluten profis die bezahlt
werden wollen bezahlen also die girls
für diese teure forschung oder
wenigstens für das schreiben des
artikels nein die forschungsarbeit wird
durch fördergelder und hochschulbudgets
aus der öffentlichen kasse also mit
unseren steuern bezahlt und auch das
schreiben gehört zu dieser arbeit dh die
bis hierhin zahlen verlage keinen cent
für ein produkt das sie anschließend
teuer verkaufen ein service mit dem
wissenschaftsverlage ihre preise
begründen ist die qualitätskontrolle
dass peer review von dem man ja immer
mal wieder hört aha bezahlen die verlage
also die vielen vielen experten die die
studien auf herz und nieren prüfen
überraschungen auch das nicht dass peer
review wird von den redakteuren des
journals nur koordiniert die
eigentlichen gutachten werden von
aktiven forscherinnen und forschern
geschrieben das wird als dienst an der
wissenschaftlichen gemeinschaft gesehen
und das ist auch gut so trotzdem ist es
arbeit die den verlagen geschenkt wird
und das ist noch nicht alles wenn der
artikel am ende veröffentlicht wird
bekommt das journal dann auch noch die
exklusiven rechte an diesem artikel und
auch für diese rechte bezahlen sie
nichts im gegenteil einige journals
verlangen von den wissenschaftlern sogar
noch geld für die bearbeitung und damit
die studierenden und forschenden die
ergebnisse dann lesen können bezahlen
die uni bibliotheken wie gesagt dann
auch noch die abogebühren diese preise
werden dafür mit dubiosen abo paketen
und geheimhaltungsklausel über die
preisverhandlungen in die höhe getrieben
das kann man eigentlich kaum glauben wie
hier unser steuergeld im großen stil und
im namen der wissenschaft in private
taschen fließt um mir das alles mal von
einem experten erklären zu lassen habe
ich mit nicolas wöhrl gesprochen er ist
an der uni duisburg-essen und ihr kennt
ihn vielleicht vom podcast methodisch
incorrect wo er zusammen mit reinhard
renfordt moderiert die verhökern euch
eigentlich nur bundles also mehrere
hundert journals diesen bundles
zusammenfassen und diese natürlich so
aufgebaut dass du sehr wichtige journals
hast du unbedingt lesen muss also so
weit wie science und nature und spezial
paper irgendwohin physik die ich
dringend braucht aber die werden
gewandelt mit irgendwann völlig
absurden journals die keinen menschen
liest nur um mit um die preise hoch zu
setzen zwar ihr kriegt hat 1000 journals
da müsst ihr natürlich auch einen
entsprechenden preis zahlen welche
preise die bibliotheken für abos
bezahlen ist wie gesagt geheim da die
verlage geheimhaltungsklausel haben
dabei sollten öffentliche institutionen
eigentlich transparent sein was ihre
ausgaben angeht also da achten die die
verlage sehr darauf dass diese preise
nicht nach außen dringen und so kommt
dann eben dass irgendwelche reichen uni
ist ein bisschen mehr zahlen und armut
ist ein bisschen weniger das ist ein
bisschen das schon so ein bisschen
dubioses geschäft wieder abläuft aber
ein bisschen kann man ahnen was hier so
für preise verlangt werden müssen denn
mit ihrem geschäftsmodell erreichen die
größten verlage gewinnmargen von bis zu
40 prozent mit diesen gewinnmargen sind
sie im branchenvergleich so weit vorne
das experten davon ausgehen dass hier
der markt wettbewerb irgendwie nicht zu
greifen scheint und das wird wie gesagt
finanziert vom steuerzahler das sind
wirtschaftsunternehmen leben geht sagen
zwar immer sie machen service für die
wissenschaft aber ich habe noch kein
service gesehen von denen die haben wir
noch nie geholfen und damit kommen wir
zur großen frage wieso verlangen die
verlage so viel geld die kurze antwort
ist weil sie es können und die lange
antwort kommt jetzt
eigentlich sollte man meinen dass die
wissenschaft die verlage in der hand
hätte denn schließlich liefern die
forschenden das produkt und sind
gleichzeitig praktisch die einzigen
kunden aber die realität sieht leider
anders aus das zeigt sich auch darin
dass schon seit vielen jahren ein
machtkampf zwischen teilen der
wissenschaft und den verlagen
stattfindet und selbst nach einem
jahrzehnt haben die verlage kaum
zugeständnisse gemacht ein grund dafür
ist dass jeder forschungsbericht
informationen beinhaltet die man
nirgendwo sonst nachlesen kann man kann
also nicht einfach mal eben bei einem
anderen anbieter shoppen gehen wenn
einem die artikel zu teuer sind der
markt wird in einer einschätzung der eu
als nicht perfekt bezeichnet weil es
eben keinen reinen wettbewerb gibt wie
in anderen märkten die bibliothek
müssten theoretisch immer alle
fachmagazine abonnieren damit ihre
forscherinnen und forscher auch optimal
informiert sind sich anderweitig zugriff
zu verschaffen ist entweder sehr
kompliziert oder vielleicht nicht immer
ganz so legal darüber haben übrigens vor
einiger zeit schon ein ganzes video
gemacht dass ihr hier finden könnt okay
das hat wirklich rein gar nichts mit dem
thema zu tun wirklich aber falls ihr mal
an informationen oder rein zufällig
irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen paper
oder sowas rankommen wolltet auf die ihr
in eurem land keinen zugriff habt dann
könnt ihr euch der sponsor der heutigen
folge vielleicht interessieren mit hilfe
von nord vpn könnt ihr quasi in über 50
länder dieser welt fliegen und das ganz
ohne endloses warten am flughafen
du kannst also auf inhalte im internet
zugreifen und muss sich dabei nicht mit
nervigen geo blocking rumschlagen nord
wie ein schützt dich jetzt außerdem auch
auf seiner suche nach informationen die
eigentlich jedem zugänglich sein sollten
und bietet ihr einen bedrohung schutz an
dem du ganz einfach aktivieren kannst
der schütze deinen pc oder laptop besser
vor schädlichen websites und dateien aus
dem internet unabhängig davon ob gerade
eine verbindung zu einem vpn server
besteht außerdem funktioniert er auch
wie ein ad blocker und verhindert so
ständig nervige popups und trekking jpn
selbst speichert nachgewiesenermaßen
keine daten über den surfer halten ist
superschnell auf tablet laptop und
computer installiert und in den ersten
30 tagen auch genauso schnell und
kostenfrei wieder weg falls es ja anders
überlegen solltest und wenn du unseren
code doktor watson oder den link norway
pr.com / doktor watson nutzt bekommst du
bei einem zwei jahres paket sogar einen
monat gratis dazu und unterstützt damit
auch noch uns und unsere videos und
damit zurück zur dunklen seite der
wissenschaft der zweite punkt ist wieder
das karriere system darüber haben wir
schon in der ersten folge dieser serie
hier gesprochen egal ob es um einen job
fördergelder eine auszeichnung oder
einfach um die veröffentlichung des
nächsten artikels geht überall an diesen
stellen sitzen forschende die ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen begutachten
sollen und das tun sie üblicherweise
nach dem motto publish or perish also
veröffentliche oder stirbt die
verführerisch einfache logik dahinter
wer im prestigeträchtigen channels
veröffentlicht und häufig zitiert wird
hat eine besonders gute
wissenschaftliche arbeit gemacht und die
wir häufig artikel veröffentlicht ist
wissenschaftlich produktiv wieso man an
dieser logik zweifeln darf dazu gleich
mehr die einzelnen forscherinnen und
forscher sehen sich also gezwungen
regelmäßig in ganz bestimmten magazinen
zu veröffentlichen um eine karriere zu
haben dadurch werden die redakteure
dieser magazine zu gatekeeper für den
zugang zu jobs forschungsmitteln und
auszeichnungen gleichzeitig werden über
50 prozent aller terminals sowohl in den
natur und medizin wissenschaften als
auch in den sozial- und
geisteswissenschaften von gerade mal
fünf verlagen veröffentlicht die top 3
und gleichzeitig bekanntesten verlage
sind elsevier springer nature und wiley
und das hat einen einfachen grund über
die letzten drei jahrzehnte haben die
sich nämlich durch käufe und fusionen
praktisch alle wichtigen journals unter
den nagel gerissen
sie kontrollieren also wer in der
wissenschaft erfolgreich ist sie
verdienen milliarden auf steuerkosten
haben dabei einen minimalen aufwand und
gleichzeitig keine richtige konkurrenz
und darunter leiden quasi alle anderen
forschende unis steuerzahler die gesamte
gesellschaft eigentlich denn wir
bekommen durch dieses system jahr
weniger forschung oder zumindest die
selbe forschung zu einem viel höheren
preis und da frage ich mich muss das so
sein
die publish or perish praxis ist
natürlich sehr bequem für die gremien
die über das einstellen von neuen
mitarbeitenden oder über auszeichnungen
und fördermittel entscheiden man kann
einfach mit ein paar zahlen herum
rechnen und andern dessen viele bewerber
schon im ersten schritt einfach
aussortieren das geht natürlich viel
schneller als deren artikel wirklich zu
lesen und inhaltlich zu bewerten
außerdem sind die gutachterinnen und
gutachter in vielen gremien nicht aus
demselben spezialgebiet und können die
inhalte teilweise auch einfach gar nicht
richtig bewerten aber
forschung ist nicht automatisch gut nur
weil sie in einem exklusiven
prestigeträchtigen journal
veröffentlicht oder weil sie häufig
zitiert wird ganz wichtiger satz
prestigeträchtig heißt meistens dass das
journal einen hohen sogenannten journal
impact factor hat details dazu findet
übrigens unter dieser quelle hier das
problem ist dass die zahlen die zur
berechnung des journal impact factors
genutzt werden manipuliert werden können
und dreimal dürft ihr raten auf die
verlage dass auch tatsächlich machen
mehr dazu findet ihr in dieser quelle
man fand außerdem heraus dass die
meisten artikel aus chanels mit einem
hohen journal impact factor nicht
häufiger zitiert werden als artikel aus
anderen journals in statistischen
qualitäts überprüfungen schneiden sie
sogar ein klein wenig schlechter ab und
sie werden häufiger wegen fehler wieder
zurückgezogen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nach dem journal impact
factor der magazine zu bewerten in denen
sie mal veröffentlicht haben ist also
nicht sinnvoll und das war vom erfinder
auch nie so gewollt dem ging es nämlich
darum ein marketingtool für dschungels
zu entwickeln und nicht um die bewertung
von forschenden deshalb sagt der journal
impact factor auch nur etwas über
journals aus und selbst das nicht
besonders gut man kann aber stattdessen
auch die zitate betrachten die einzelne
artikel bekommen daraus berechnet man
zum beispiel den hirsch index oder auch
age index für einzelne forschende ist
das vielleicht sinnvoller sie schaut man
sich ja zumindest einzelne arbeiten an
und nicht in welchem journal meine
artikel stehen aber auch das
funktioniert leider nicht wirklich wie
häufig einzelne artikel eines kandidaten
zitiert werden hängt von vielen faktoren
ab die nichts mit wissenschaftlichen
skills zu tun haben man kann zum
beispiel einfach einen artikel auf
twitter teilen das korreliert
tatsächlich mit höheren zitationen
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie wissenschaft und
es kommt noch krasser eine weitere
studie hat gezeigt dass unzuverlässige
wissenschaftliche arbeiten häufiger
zitiert wurden als zuverlässiger und das
sogar nachdem die arbeiten widerlegt
wurden das soll ein bisschen wie bei
facebook auch da werden die fake news
besonders häufig geteilt also die erste
große annahme hinter publish or perish
ist falsch prestige und zitationen sind
keine zuverlässige einheit um die skills
von wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern abzubilden trotzdem
passiert das jeden tag die zweite
annahme hinter publish or perish ist
dass forscher besonders produktiv sein
müssen wenn ihre namen auf vielen
artikeln auftauchen das problem damit
ist dass die autorenschaft durch publish
or perish zu einer strategischen
entscheidung geworden ist die innerhalb
eines forschungsteams hinter
verschlossenen türen ausgehandelt wird
es gibt zum beispiel die ähren
autorenschaft wo jemand mit auf dem
artikel steht obwohl diese personen fast
nichts beigetragen hat das sind oft
führende professoren in den instituten
ein weiterer punkt wäre das besonders
gewissenhafte und ethisch korrekt
vorgehende forscherinnen und forscher ja
eigentlich seltener veröffentlichen zum
einen weil sie mehr zeit brauchen um
gute forschung zu machen und zum anderen
weil sie nicht versuchen vier schläge
noch irgendwie als erfolge umzudeuten
erfolge lassen sich eben viel leichter
veröffentlichen als fehlschläge das
nennt man den publication bei ist er hat
wohl unter anderem damit zu tun dass
viele erfolge seltener zitiert werden
und studien die wenig zitiert werden
helfen dem journal eben nicht dabei den
journal impact factor zu optimieren der
veröffentlichungs druck erzeugt außerdem
schlechte anreize für die forschenden da
gibt es zum beispiel peer reviewer die
verlangen dass ihre eigenen artikel
zitiert werden und es gibt situations
kartelle in dem man sich immer
gegenseitig zitiert also einfach im
kreis ganze fachgebiete veröffentlichen
artikel mit unzuverlässigen daten was zu
replikations krisen führt auch hierzu
findet ihr weitere details unten in den
quellen manipulierte fotos von
versuchsergebnissen in artikeln werden
zu tausenden jedes jahr aufgedeckt und
2009 flogen sogar einige professoren in
göttingen auf die sich artikel in den
lebenslauf geschrieben hatten dies
überhaupt nicht gibt
zusammengefasst weder das prestige eines
tunnels noch die situationen eines
artikels sind zuverlässige anzeichen für
das wissenschaftliche können von
forscherinnen und forschern und der
publikations druck führt zu schlechter
forschung fehlender kollegialität und
sogar zu unethischem und betrügerischen
verhalten
okay okay ich weiß das weil es eine
menge deswegen versucht dass hier einmal
ganz kurz zusammenzufassen also
wissenschaftsverlage verdienen viel mehr
geld als sie müssten sie machen mit
öffentlichen geldern milliarden weil
sich die wissenschaft durch publish or
perish von ihnen unnötigerweise abhängig
gemacht hat das haben uns auch
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in hintergrundgesprächen bestätigt die
annahme dass wir verlage brauchen damit
sich wissenschaftler gegenseitig
bewerten können ist ein fataler irrtum
dazu wird sich der publikations druck
negativ auf die arbeitsbedingungen und
die qualität der forschung aus hat sich
die wissenschaft also vom marketing der
wissenschaftsverlage einen bären
aufbinden lassen vielleicht vielleicht
ist sie aber auch ganz von allein auf
diese idee gekommen vielleicht ein wenig
von beidem sie hat sich so auf jeden
fall in eine zwickmühle manövriert die
man nur lösen kann wenn man die regeln
des spiels ändert aber die notwendigen
veränderungen gehen nur äußerst langsam
voran zu langsam wie es scheint um die
schlimmsten auswirkungen zu verhindern
es gibt natürlich bewegungen das
akademische system zu ändern wichtige
stichpunkte die ihr vielleicht kennen
solltet wenn ihr selbst in der forschung
seit während zum beispiel preprint
server und open access
veröffentlichungen aber auch die san
francisco declaration und research
assessment oder das projekt die quellen
zu all diesen themen findet ihr unten in
der video beschreibung ihr werdet
schnell merken dass das ein sehr
komplexes thema mit vielen verschiedenen
meinungen zu vielen verschiedenen
technischen details ist die wir hier
leider aus zeitlichen gründen nicht
abdecken können apropos zeit auch dieses
video hier war wieder super aufwendig
sagt mega viel spaß gemacht wir sind
weiterhin der überzeugung dass wir
unbedingt über diese themen sprechen
müssen am letzten video haben wir pajun
geplagt und haben gesagt bitte
unterstützt uns doch da und einige von
euch haben uns geschrieben dass er etwas
monatliches ist wir uns aber gerne nur
einmalig unterstützen wollt deswegen
haben wir ein paypal konto eingerichtet
wo er genau das tun könnt es wird uns
sehr freuen wenn wir das machen würdet
wenn ihr das geld hat wie immer vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
patrick
man muss